kansas is just one of five states that
held key primary contests yesterday and
some of the gop candidates backed by
former president trump are celebrating
others are not ed o'keefe is keeping
track of the results in arizona ed good
morning
nate good to see you they're still
counting votes out here in the west but
it was a very good night for candidates
who don't accept the results of the 2020
elections and it'll be interesting to
see how they hold up in general election
contests this fall
i guess there's no turning back now is
there
with votes still being counted in
arizona's republican gubernatorial
primary karen taylor robson backed by
former vice president mike pence is
claiming victory robson is neck and neck
with opponent carrie lake the former tv
news anchor backed by former president
donald trump believes the 2020 election
was stolen she's also claiming victory
[Music]
the winner will face off against
democratic nominee katie hobbs meanwhile
in arizona's senate race democrat mark
kelly is set to face off against
trump-backed venture capitalist blake
masters another election denier and yet
another trump-backed candidate mark
fincham has won the gop race for
secretary of state
he's an election denier and has been one
of the loudest voices promoting the
former president's unsubstantiated
claims that the election was rigged if
he wins in november he would oversee
arizona's elections
then there's the u.s senate race in
missouri i am honored to be your nominee
for the united states senate
national republicans are breathing a
sigh of relief that eric schmidt
defeated vicki hartzler and eric
greitens the controversial former
governor of missouri was being accused
of glorifying political violence today
we're going rhino hunting i want to make
this a better state and in michigan
tudor dixon won the gop nomination for
governor she believes the 2020 election
was stolen and will face off against
democratic incumbent gretchen whitmer
seeking a second term
and in another closely watched race in
michigan republican congressman peter
meyer loses his primary to trump endorse
challenger john gibbs myers in his first
term he voted to impeach the former
president after the january 6 riots
we're also keeping tabs on two house
republicans from washington state who
also voted to impeach donald trump to
see if they hold on into november vlad
all right ed thank you very much